[Musique]
un jour j'irai là où là haut c'est
sagarmatha la déesse mère pour les mets
pas les mouches mulumba la sainte mère
de l'univers pour les tibétains
c'est ce que j'avais dit lors d'une
expédition en himalaya et ce matin là
nous étions au sommet du mont gokyo à
5600 mètres d'altitude est face à nous
des centaines et des centaines de
sommets himalayens
un jour j'irai là où là haut c'est la
frontière la plus haute du monde entre
antibes et muselé et intime un népal
souriant un jour j'irai là où là où
c'est l'everest le toit du monde 8848
mètres juste à peu près altitude
laquelle volent les airbus et boeing
13 ans jour pour jour après avoir
prononcé cette phrase je suis au sommet
de l'everest
j'ai réalisé mon rêve de gosse le plus
fou je me tiens sur le pic le plus
proche des étoiles le plus proche du
cosmos et du soleil mais gravir
l'everest répond à un certain nombre de
protocoles qu'il est dangereux de
transgresser idéalement il faut d'abord
gravir des sommets de plus de 6000 m
quelques semaines de 7000 mètres un ou
deux sommets de 8000 m un programme qui
prend des années et des années
impossible pour un type à la tête d'une
entreprise de plus de 120 personnes
impossible pour un type qui tient un
petit peu à sa vie de famille impossible
surtout pour un type qui s'était produit
en 2010 d'aller fêter ses 40 ans au
sommet de l'everest alors il m'a fallu
transgresser tous ces protocoles
il m'a fallu sauter le pas comme pour
franchir ces immenses crevasse du
glacier du khumbu qui barre l'accès à la
voie népal du sommet de l'everest côté
népalais aujourd'hui avec la même
méthode
la même organisation et de la même
manière qu'il faut passer par des camps
d'acclimatation pour aller sur le toit
du monde
je vous propose d'aller explorer les
différents camps les différents ressorts
du passage à l'action ou comment pour se
réaliser pour vous réaliser passer à
l'action et le facteur-clé de vos
réussites futures
alors si vous êtes prêts ce sont les
crampons prenons les piolets et partout
en direction du camp de base de la
réussite
le rêve première étape avant de sauter
le pas il faut un rêve un projet c'est
le plus important
sans rêve pas de désir sans désir pas
d'audace et si chacun porte en lui un
rêve
encore faut-il l'identifier ce rêve dont
on est sûr que si on le réalise pas on
regrettera toute sa vie et la vie ne se
négocie pas la vie est unique c'est ce
que j'appelle le train de la destinée un
train qui ne passent qu'une seule fois
et tant qu'à faire autant rêver en grand
en audacieux un peu comme elon musk ce
type que tout le monde connaît désormais
qui après avoir envoyé une tesla dans
l'espace à bord de l'une de ces fusées
après avoir conçu fabriqué et prouver
qu'on pouvait réutiliser des fusées un
nouveau projet évidemment à base de
fusées et ce projet il s'appelle de big
fucking roquettes littéralement la
de grosses fusée avec ça ils
comptent envoyer les passagers d'un
point a à un point b de la planète en
passant par l'atmosphère à 27 milles
kilomètres heure paris new york 27
minutes
bangkok dubaï 30 minutes le rêve de
gosse d'elon musk c'était de construire
des fusées il y est parvenu avec un
acharnement incroyable et une disruption
aussi extraordinaire de toute la chaîne
de valeur de la conception de la
construction d'une fusée et aujourd'hui
c'est le plus grand concurrent de la
nasa
moi j'ai juste rêver d'aller vers
l'everest
diddy ce que j'ai fait j'ai fait ce que
je dis j'allais faire c'est aussi simple
que ça rien de plus efficace en termes
d'exemplarité pour un manager un leader
mais aussi pour un père est là haut
depuis mon belvédère dao depuis le toit
du monde
j'ai eu l'immense privilège d'assister
ce matin-là un extraordinaire lever de
soleil sur l'immensité de la planète
mais avant de fouler le toit du monde
il m'aura fallu en franchir des étapes
et des trucs soi-disant impossible à
réaliser et à un moment donné pour
réaliser ses rêves il va falloir
pratiquer ce qu'on appelle le
dépassement de soi et sortir de sa zone
de confort mais il faudra aussi de la
constance de la persévérance de la
volonté de l'opiniâtreté de
l'obstination bref ne rien lâcher
tony estanguet triple champion olympique
de canoë triple champion du monde de
canoë 20 ans au plus haut niveau mondial
de sa discipline
nous le rappelle dans son livre une
histoire d' équilibre si tu choisis une
voix met tous les atouts de son côté ne
fait pas les choses à moitié
et surtout surtout ne lâche rien car
vous allez devoir affronter des armées
de gens qui vous soutiendrons preuve
scientifique à l'appui qu'il sera
impossible de réaliser votre rêve
c'est ce qui est passionnant avec
l'impossible des autres c'est de rendre
possible pour vous allez faire l'everest
sans avoir fait d'autres sommets de plus
de 8000 mètres
impossible à l'hfr l'everest à la tête
d'une entreprise de plus de 120
personnes en la laissant en autogestion
pendant plusieurs mois impossibles à
l'hfr l'everest
pendant la plus grave crise financière
de ces dernières décennies la crise des
subprimes impossible beaucoup de gens me
prenaient pour un fou alors je ne les ai
pas entendu mieux et c'est là toute la
différence
je ne les ai pas écouté alors fuyez les
gens négatifs
ils ont un problème pour chaque solution
ça c'est pas de moi c'est de albert
einstein
alors on va remonter un peu dans notre
histoire ou plutôt dans notre
préhistoire pour imager un peu le propos
néandertal quand il partait chassait le
mammouth avec ses flèches ssige se
posait pas de question de savoir c'était
possible ou pas possible non ils y
allaient le type avec la fois au ventre
avec la fin aussi bien sûr alors nous
devrions tous nous remet murray nos
premières
parties de chasse au mammouth pour
relativiser notre perception de
l'impossible car l'impossible en réalité
n'est là que pour que nous le
transformions impossible c'est juste
impossible en attente pour que nous
revisitions nos propres limites et
qu'elle limite d'ailleurs des limites
que les autres les amis la famille les
parents la société nous impose
souvenez-vous les fameux saboteur dont
je vous parlais tout à l'heure celles et
ceux qui vous affirme que c'est
impossible
alors soyez néandertal prenait des
risques et moi s'il ya bien un risque
que je ne veux pas prendre dans la vie
c'est de ne pas prendre de risque ne pas
rester dans ma zone d'inconfort
car je sais qu'elle peut devenir aussi
une sacrée zone d'inconfort les zones de
confort sont peuplés de décisions qu'on
ne prend pas et qui laisse fatalement
mourir à petit feu
tous nos rêves les plus chers vous savez
cette propension à l'immobilisme qui
prévaut quand il s'agit de quitter un
terrain connu
alors comme nous sommes acclimater que
tout va bien poursuivons vers le camp
supérieur ou comment sublimer les doute
rêvé identifier le bon rêve se heurter à
l'impossible des autres prendre des
risques telles sont les premières clés
de vos réussites futures
une fois que vous avez trouvé cette
harmonie fondatrice ce projet qui est en
vous viendra le nécessaire temps du
passage à l'action
mailly s'il ya pas de passage à l'action
il va rien se passer et pour toute chose
il y a un prix à payer
savez vous comment ils faisaient
néandertal pour manger le mammouth qui
l'avait chassé du bout de la trompe
jusqu'au bout de la queue petites
bouchées par petites bouchées et la
stratégie est la même pour tous les
grands projets avancer étape par étape
pour ne pas proscrit steen et écrivez
votre projet rédiger votre projet
ensuite donnez vous une deadline pour
démarrer ce projet apprenez à pratiquer
le rétroplanning parlez-en au plus grand
nombre possible autour de vous comme ça
vous pourrez plus faire machine arrière
vous pourrez plus vous déjuger et en
apprenant le rétroplanning apprenez à
décomposer phase par phase micro projets
par microprojets petites bouchées par
petit bout
hélas deux stratégies s'opposent la
stratégie numéro un c'est la stratégie
des cartes stratégie numéro deux c'est
la stratégie des cartes la stratégie des
cartes consiste à se comporter comme
tous les bons consultants qui auditent
analyse expertise et qui à partir des
matrices de spots bâtissent des plans
d'actions al'inverse de l'esprit qui
analysent vérifie les chiffres et bâti
des plans d'actions la stratégie des
cartes consiste d'abord à faire
fonctionner votre intuition alors
résonner al'inverse de 95% des
consultants qui se disent voilà toutes
les cartes que j'ai entre mes mains
qu'est ce que je peux bien en faire et
posez vous la question de savoir quel
est votre projet quel est votre rêve est
allé chercher une à une les cartes qu'il
vous manque
en d'autres termes prenez les décisions
en fonction de là où vous voulez aller
et non pas de là où vous êtes
c'est ce que j'ai fait pour ce grand
projet sur l'everest
alors réaliser son rêve de gosse c'est
bien le réaliser avec éthique c'est
mieux et c'est pour ça que j'ai organisé
la première expédition française de
dépollution de l'everest
car s'il est vrai c'est bel et bien la
plus haute montagne du monde c'est aussi
la plus haute des charges du monde la
plus haute poubelle du monde le plus aux
chiottes du monde depuis des décennies
des centaines et des centaines
d'expéditions ont abandonné sur les
contreforts de l'himalaya des tonnes et
des tonnes de déchets la pollution par
l'homme delà des plus beaux sites
naturels au monde les neiges éternelles
de l'himalaya et c'est de ce constat
qu'est né ce double projet un projet
pour moi bien sûr mais aussi un projet
pour la nature pour l'environnement pour
les générations futures
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce projet a donné naissance à d'autres
projets ce que j'appelle des projets
héritiers je pense notamment à
l'expédition de mon ami gérard claire
midi everest green 2017 qui a le
collecté est redescendu 5 tonnes des
contreforts de l'himalaya il ya cette
jeune française marion chaigneau du
puits qui s'est assigné à nettoyer
dépolluer aussi les différents camps de
base de l'everest sauter le pas en
réalité c'est l'alchimie de toutes ces
notions inséparables souvenez-vous du
camp de base le rêve la promesse un jour
j'irai là où alors rêver en grand rêver
en audacieux ensuite
souvenez-vous du camp supérieur ou
comment rendre l'impossible possible
prenez des risques soyez néandertal
oublier les limites des hôtes
sortez de votre zone de confort et
surtout ne lâchez rien le sommet en
réalité c'est le passage à l'action
enclenchée le mode projet manger le
mammouth petites bouchées par petites
bouchées donnez vous une deadline est
appliqué la stratégie des cartes mais
pas la stratégie des cartes
ce que j'ai appris en allant au sommet
de l'everest
c'est ce que j'ai appris sur moi mais
aussi sur le monde qu'il faut de
l'audace bien sûr prendre des risques
sortir de sa zone de confort mais
surtout surtout qu'il faut passer à
l'action
le philosophe sénèque nous le rappelle
dans sa grande sagesse
ce n'est pas parce que ce sont
difficiles que nous n'osons pas mais
parce que nous n'osons pas qu'elles sont
difficiles
merci infiniment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]